rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's even my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message have a
plan over to you Chris Gardner
[Music]
pour message that I would like to share
with people is Chris Gardner did it is
soaking you Chris Gardner's not doing
anything that you could not do but
you've got to be able to commit to some
things you've got to be able to commit
to doing something that you are truly
passionate about it can't just be I want
to make money everybody wants to make
money it can't just be about money it's
got to be about something that you're
truly passionate about and you can't
just have hope you've got to have a plan
part of the core message would be you've
got to have a plan
and your plan has got to have what I
call to my last book start where you are
something that called the c5 complex
your plan has got to be clear concise
compelling consistent and committed
you've got to have a point I'm on a
mission to solve the world's biggest
problem and that is untapped human
potential I think it's the biggest
problem in the world and I want to help
contribute to solving that and it's
something that's never done but when I
came up with is what I call the circle
of potential it's on my website you can
check it out
it starts with self awareness it starts
with figuring out your one word says
with knowing who you are what you stand
for what you are no longer willing to
accept or tolerant in your life and then
the next step is having an action plan
you need to know what you're gonna do
right like have a plan for what you want
to do it's not enough to just be
self-aware it's not enough to just know
your core value it's not enough just to
be motivated every day you got to do
something like for people who who watch
the videos or who read the books it's
not enough just to watch the video read
the book for anybody who's making
content the end goal is a result like we
want you to go up and do something that
was much rather you watch one video a
day or one video a week and you're off
taking amazing action and you come back
when you need it as opposed to watching
every single video and then doing
nothing my biggest goal is the untapped
human potential is helping you guys
believe in yourself and not having you
just be addicted to coming back
consistently but not doing anything
whatever I don't know what to do and to
create an action plan because that can
be scary right like I want to launch
this new thing I have no idea how to do
it how do I launch a beauty company how
do I launch a speaking company how do I
launch a YouTube channel how do I do any
of these things that you want to do my
number one go-to is some model success
this is what saved my business in my
first company biotech software I knew
nothing about ethics offer was failing
we give here no bucks a month just
sucking and then looking at how did Bill
Gates build Microsoft saved my company
looking at successful people in my field
saved my company and so model of success
is the number one piece of advice I have
for you in terms of creating an action
plan so you have the self-awareness you
have some motivation habits in the team
you have to create an action plan to
actually do and in terms of picking the
steps find the person done
you want to do other people and it's
inside during this tree is also outside
like you may love Steve Jobs he's up on
my wall you may not want to build a
technology company you can still learn a
lot the people who you look up to and
respect you like them for a reason and
so they have aspects about them that you
look up to and they have a game plan
that you look up to look at that game
plan you're not gonna have success just
by copying them you're gonna have to
twist it to find your own model but it
gives you a rough road map and a place
to start when I was doing training for
my videos I have a agent in New York and
I had about two years of training maybe
a year and a half of training every week
I had a a one-on-one call for about an
hour
where Jani was a communications trainer
would work with me on my videos we
dissect videos and every week she give
me feedback and advice and almost every
week none of her advice specifically
stuck that sounds really bad but it was
great because I would try what she gave
me it would feel super uncomfortable and
not genuine but then I would find a way
to make it my own and it would make me
better she would say say these words to
try this exercise and I didn't like it
they push my boundaries push my comfort
zone and I still did it I tried it
because I want to learn and grow but I
couldn't do it exactly as she told me I
had to find my own path I had to
customize it and adjust it but I
couldn't adjust it until I tried it her
way first so all these people you look
up to these entrepreneurs these
celebrities who ever try it their way
it won't work exactly the same way but
it gives you a rough blueprint a rough
template and then adjust because your
goal is not to be the next Steve Jobs to
be the best you and you're gonna pull
different things and different people in
order to accomplish that and so having
an action plan is super important don't
get worried about having the perfect
first step there's no such thing people
asked me what is it how do I start
what's the first step there is no
perfect person don't worry about perfect
first step doesn't exist just do
something you want to have a YouTube
career great follow my channel look at
PewDiePie's channel look whoever you
look up to follow their channel look at
how they got started and then try that
and then adjust and then try something
else and adjust you're not just trying
random things you tried things that have
worked for people you tried things that
have had a proven track record of
success and it's not going to work
exactly for you but you're gonna learn
something and you're gonna adjust from
it so don't be crippled
they'll be paralyzed by having a perfect
plan does your plane is gonna change
thousand times before you become a
massive success that's okay but that
doesn't mean you don't plan either such
as that you're off doing with zero plan
it's a mix your planning and your doing
and your planning and your doing and
you're planning on your doing having the
action plan is a critical piece to you
getting out of bed waking up every
morning and doing something to move
closer to turning your business in Korea
so the question of the day today is I'm
curious what is one super important
piece on your current action plan what
are some of the to do's that you need to
do in your business then maybe even been
holding off and now you're gonna put a
little bit of extra grind into what are
those things
leaving the comments below really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick Trevor to Daren Spencer bets
there and thank you so much for picking
up a cup of my book you're one where it
really really means a lot to me so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you and I hope you continue to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word
is I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
that's like a business plan that's about
a business that doesn't exist is a lie
because you can't you can't say like
what are your facts based on because it
hasn't happened that you can't really
determine who's going by what and how
much it's gonna sell you can't say I'm
gonna make a million this year doesn't
make a million no but what I'll do was
put together what it's like a script I
put together how we make the goods how
I'm gonna market the goods how much it's
gonna cost to buy the goods but we have
with my margin and then when I'm gonna
sell it and then how much I'm gonna put
back into the business and how much I'm
gonna put in my part you know it's that
kind of thing you know I write things
that like if you look look one put that
on the wall right there right you see
you see it depict a piece of paper while
I don't own it that's what I got to do
you know I like to put things on the
wall I can even know what I've got to do
I need to look at it and it cross it out
I don't consider that a business plan
per se or but I have a plan you know I'm
saying like I have a plan plus you want
other people to understand the plan
because you can't do anything on your
own so you want to be able to articulate
it to them away they understand and that
they could look back at because I talked
quick and like you said a lot of times I
say [ __ ] you like I didn't understand
that tell me until 10 a year later yeah
you know so you want to have something
someone could keep looking at and they
could see you crossing it off and then
they can kind of get it by absorbing
cause you know by watching what you're
doing how much have you changed as a
creative person a lot well I'm learning
so much I mean I mean I'm learning so
much we're doing um when when I come up
with a good idea I stick with it that's
the difference i I can come up with a
lot of ideas but anyone can you know
when I come up with something you know
what this is something that's capable of
me growing and I still will like this
this is something that's big enough and
ambitious enough that in four years from
now if I really want to become a space
engineer and build spaceships I could
probably put those spaceships and the
movie or the book or something you know
yeah that's kind of how I think come up
with projects that can last long time
and grow and then as I grow I'm still
interested and yet created so I yeah but
I plan for that I plan for my evolving
mmm
my idea is it number-three unbelievably
important which is the importance of
scheduling you know I talk a lot of a
lot about having a dream having a plan
you know being inspired but all ideas
don't work unless you do the work and
some of the best work you can do is
getting really good at creating a one
page plan have your big five the five
things that need to happen this year for
this to be your best year yet on a one
page plan your top five values put them
on that same plan your top five sub
goals sequenced into each quarter of
this year on that one page plan and
every morning all your competition or
the rest of the world is asleep get up
at 5 a.m. I'll teach you how to do that
in future videos but look at your one
page plan it spend 20 minutes on that so
it becomes a brain tattoo a burning
obsession so it all lights you with
inspiration so you go up in the world
and you understand the clarity is power
and you so intimately know what has to
happen during this day this week this
month this quarter this year to get you
closer to your mountain top because the
ordinary though the hours that ordinary
people waste extraordinary people do
because they're not bored like most
people most people need to medicate
themselves with too much TV too much
Facebook too much video too much
chitchat too much busyness because they
don't know their goals because they
don't have a one-page plan because they
don't have a one-page schedule I mean
I've got my schedule for every 7 days
almost everything I need to do goes on
it and you might say Robin well that's a
very rigid way to live no it's a very
free way to live because then I have the
power to live life on my own terms I
feel inspired I'm not wasting each day
I'm leveraging each day raise your
standard Apple at the core its core
values is that people with passion and
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something Sammy
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten rose a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details